hello everyone and welcome to another
game that could have a pretty pretty big
impact on the feeder candidates
tournament it is being learned versus
tamara jabov if you remember from
yesterday ding is currently second in
the standings uh here are the standings
if some of you forgot after the
after yesterday's round ding with six
and a half points uh trailing uh uh by
uh by a point and a half behind nepo who
is first with eight out of eleven so now
a win against uh uh rajabov here would
go a long way uh as for those of you who
still don't know i will now spoil the
result uh between uh yanni ponch and
hikaru nakamura that game ended in a
draw so i hope you guys were ready for
that and we can even show the game
before we show this one because it
lasted exactly seven minutes uh it was
the uh
the famous um uh draw that we've seen
many many times on this channel just
bishop to b5 the berlin defense of
course castles knight captures an e4 d4
knight to d6 going after the bishop and
now sacrificing the bishop again it's
been seen many times the so-called
hermit variation we have a4 attacking
the knight knight to d4 you have to give
up one of the knights captures captures
and after queen characters now we play
d5 and here after e captures on d6 alpha
we have a draw by repetition you could
of course continue playing this but uh
both of them know that it is nothing you
can go some like queen to d3 or maybe
knight to c3 but here it just captures
alpha song queen captures and now we
have this queenie for chair queen e6
queen d4 queen to d6 uh and um
just a nice repetition here a famous
grandmaster draw that um pretty much
everyone uses if they want a quick draw
so the draw was uh
what both uh nakamura and
nipponshi were interested in nepo as
he's leading with such a huge margin he
doesn't want to risk anything and hikaru
also doesn't want to risk too much
because a second place might also
mean a shot at the title since magnus
still has not decided if he's going to
play but okay that's about that game now
checking out this one we even have a
nice photo of it there you have it ding
with white against rajaba with black
jabba as usual wearing exclusively black
he only wears black as as far as i know
ended being uh wearing the exact same
thing he wore yesterday as he won a very
nice game so why change anything uh you
know chess players are superstitious
like that now getting back to the actual
game adding with the white pieces opens
with d4 he does not go for the english
he goes for the queen's pawn opening
knight to f6 we have c4 uh e6 knight the
c3 and now bishop to be for a job of
ghost for the nimzo indian defense and
uh of course you know that good good
things happen when uh that that happens
so e3
uh queen to c2 and d3 are the standard
replies ding chooses the e3 one castles
and now bishop to d3 going for the
bishop attack we have d5 c captures e
captures and now a3 already mixes it up
a little bit knight after d2 is the the
e2 is the standard move here that um
pretty much everyone plays but he goes
for the somewhat rare a3 challenges the
bishop bishop backed the d6 and now
queen to c2 puts pressure on the h7 pawn
we have knight to a6 by rajabov and now
knight g to e2 we have c5 striking in
the center and now uh we have the exact
position that already happened but it
happened almost 100 years ago uh 90
years ago to be exact in 1932 between
paul johnner and effin bogaluv uh where
uh the game continued with d captures on
c5 and bolivia we've lost that game but
here we have bishop captures an a6
biting and it is now already as of move
10 that we have a completely new game so
b captures on a6 rajabov now has a
shattered pawn structure here but you
know from practice that this usually
doesn't yield all that much d captures
on c5 bishop captures and pawn to b4
grabbing more space preparing to fiance
to the light square dark square bishop
uh bishop to d6 and bishop to b2 and now
as arjab will already castle his king to
safety he has time to uh well to waste
one of his doubled pawns the ruined
ding's pawn structure on the queen side
so a5 and the ding of course doesn't
want to do that he advances the pawn to
b5 we have a6 challenging the pawn again
and now pawn to h3 just
preventing anything uh from reaching
that g4 square and after the king
castles and maybe giving the king a
little bit of breeding room uh but of
course not all that relevant as the
bishop covers that but that that's for
now so bishop to d7 uh developing
putting pressure on that b5 pawn and
only now b captures on a6 we have rook
captures and now rook to d1 putting
pressure on that d5 pawn but now rook to
b6 just putting pressure on the bishop
here
and what do you play here uh well with
your king in the center of the board it
would of course be uh a very sad idea to
go after the pawn here for example
knight captures rook captures and now
you just allow all sorts of nasty ideas
like queen to b8 uh putting pressure on
the bishop also just
controlling this diagonal beautifully
the other rook is coming to c8 so you do
not want to do this with your king in
the center of the board uh you will not
survive this so bishop to a1 is a move
that should be played here but okay ning
plays rook to d2 and now it's going to
be a a little bit difficult for him to
play this here at a java place rook to
c8 even though the queen belongs on b8
and this rook should come to c8 but even
with this uh uh well sort of a move
wasting position uh the ding's position
is so bad already that uh rajab can even
afford to waste a move like this so
queen to c8
we have f3 by ding also a very very
interesting choice here
bishop to a1 is is definitely the way to
go you have to give up the a3 pawn
there's no better way than this and now
you castle and you try and play this
being down upon black has the outside
pass pawn and it will be hard but it
might be possible however after dings f3
this is now incredibly difficult the e3
pawn has now been weakened and rajabo
goes for rook to e8
another interesting try was of course d4
and another interesting try was queen to
b8 because the queen really
belongs on this b8 square just putting
pressure on this bishop here and if for
example white castles then rook the c8
to just
so much pressure
and also d4 is very interesting because
uh well the knight really doesn't want
to capture because of bishop to g3 check
if you capture with the pawn then you
allow rook to e8 also very annoying
uh and if rook captures on d4 then queen
to b8 another uh very very annoying move
the bishop would be hanging as the rook
moved from d2 and uh you are putting
more and more pressure on that g3 square
so here you would have to move the
bishop now comes bishop c5 and this is
uh a terrible terrible for white if not
lost but okay
like we said went for this rook the e8
move goes after the weak uh e3 pawn and
now ding doesn't defend it with knight
to d1 uh and offers a queen trade but
rather plays king to f2 and this is now
becoming very very interesting uh
because knights the d1 uh
is fine but of course uh rejava would
not trade you would go rook to c6 and
still it would be a terrible terrible
position uh there are even tricks like
let's say queen to b3 a4 you give up the
pawn and after queen captures now a nice
discovery from the bishop and the rook
queen b3 now bishop to a4 and after
queen to d3 now bishop to c2 and you
would be forced to give up your rook and
of course the black would be black would
be just winning here so instead king to
f2 and and there are no good moves here
unfortunately for ding and now comes
queen to b8 finally the queen uh gets to
this uh
square that we we already mentioned but
you can see how rojava should have
played it right away but the ding's
position is just so bad uh even before
move 20 that rajab can just waste the
move and then play queen to b8 again
and
again terrible terrible position you
have to play something like bishop to c1
or queen to c1 uh but it doesn't help uh
being played queen to c1 which is which
is far far worse than bishop to c1
because now rajabo has such a
spectacular move to end the game but i'm
not going to show it to you feel free to
pause the video and win this game for a
job of in a most spectacular fashion
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on playing any move
because pretty much any move wins here
like d4 but for those of you who found
the absolute brutal
rook captures an e3 congratulations you
are an extremely precise player this is
what rajab played and now there is no
good move for the if if the king
captures then it's just
well bishop to c5 check
you really don't have all that many
squares you have to block knight to d4
now we play queen to e5 with czech king
f2 and now bishop captures on d4 you you
just start winning material here uh king
to f1 you're gonna play knight to the h5
now you threaten knight to g3 checkmate
and there's a really no good way to to
deal with this you have to uh you have
to play something like knight to e2 but
this is just gonna uh you know cost you
too much material for example rook
captures on b2 rook captures the bishop
captures the queen now has to move uh
it's a terrible terrible uh position uh
okay you you could play f4 like offer or
for a queen trade here but uh uh
anything is just winning here for black
even a nice queen captures an e2 trick
that's also winning for example king
captures now uh first we're going to
capture the queen and after rook
captures on c1 knight captures an f4
check and uh still it's two two pieces
uh against the rook you're up you're up
two pawns of course this will be
completely winning but you can play it
much much better than this this is just
to show you that absolutely everything
is winning so instead after rook
captures an e3 ding tries knight to d1
attacks the rook now this way and now
ding has 27 minutes on the clock rajabo
has 53 minutes on the clock and here he
goes back rook to e8 if rajabo really
wanted to waste time here he could just
play rook captures on e2 even this is in
the position but uh
every move that rejevo plays is just
winning so it's hard to
to force yourself to waste time to just
find that move that you know
it just wins the the the uh the most
properly so so to say uh but yeah even
this wins because now for example if
rook captures an e2 we're just going to
play bishop to g3 check and after king
to g1 there's uh
i mean
your entire position is
completely busted there's no good way to
play this everything is hanging and
i mean
even if you had something this rook will
never see the light of day it's just one
of the sadder positions that we've ever
shown on the channel and if you don't
capture with the rook if you capture
with the king it's not much better
because now bishop b5 check and after
king f2 again bishop g3
this is just uh resigns there's no good
way to play this king g1
queen to e8 going after e1 uh it's uh
just disgusting to even look at this
position uh but okay after knight to d1
or java just brought the rook back rook
to e8 uh you can you know if you threw
pieces uh you know with your
eyes closed you would probably play a
winning move here
knights the e3 and now rook to b3
attacking the knight here knight to g4
and now rajab just captures it bishop
captures h captures and rook to c8 going
after the queen here queen to a1 and
here uh rajab just played bishop to f4
and he was in this position on move 26
that dean liran resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
a most unusual turn of events ding after
winning three games in a row loses with
the white pieces uh pretty much before
move 20. he he probably messed up his
preparation or something because it's uh
it's hard to believe that this is your
your attempt after after you know
basically snowballing the second half of
the tournament and now
now you just play this it's um i have no
idea what happened here we will have to
wait for ding to clarify in the in an
interview perhaps but uh what whatever i
mean of course rajava played brilliantly
uh not saying that but um
dean with the white pieces to lose like
this this is uh you know
once or twice in in a lifetime that that
something like this could happen uh so
yeah really impressive stuff here you
resign uh you don't really have a move
the rook can't really move away from the
defense of the bishop and if you capture
the bishop uh we're just gonna play
queen captures on f4 attack the rook and
once you move the rook then just
everything falls apart knight captures
on g4 check king to f1 now even rook
captures an f3 you can play this
position any way you want queen captures
king e1 or g1 then we capture this rook
or e1 then we capture this rook with
czech king d2 for example queen h6 check
we don't trade queens here king to a1
and now it's a pawn to d4 and there is
no move here for white quickly you will
you will checkmate the white king of
course the pawn cannot be captured as
rook the c1 the bishop is needed here to
cover this square uh there just aren't
any moves here for for thing to make
so of course he knows this after bishop
to f4 he resigns and a brilliant
brilliant victory for timur rajabov in
round 12 of defeating candidates
tournament uh so this is a tough tough
break for ding he does not get closer to
tayaniponishi as if you guys remember
these were the standings oops
this were the standings after uh the
previous round so ding was uh uh one and
a half points behind nipple so now he
remains here but rajabo jumps from five
to six and now uh well uh it might be a
bit difficult uh we're gonna wait for
the other games to finish and then we're
going to show the standings after round
12 uh because it's uh it's not going to
be easy to catch uh nipple now uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
michael uh hope for consulting alan
chevalier moore uh obrad mishkovic
jeffrey cook and abhishek babu for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament until it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day